معنى من ادلب احمد يازجي عضو مجلس الدفاع
المدني اداره الدفاع المدني السوري السيد
احمد هل لديكم معلومات جديده
وما هو العمل الذي تقومون به الان
هنالك
شمال غرب سوريا ادى هذا زلزلان الى التصدع
في بعض المباني بالاضافه الى انهيار بعض
المباني التي كانت مصدعه سابقا زلزال
السابق
فرقا استنفرت بالكامل على كامل محيط شمال
سوريا تفقدت المدن وحتى القرى جميعا يوجد
بعض المباني التي تهدمت جراء هذا
الزلزالين بالاضافه ولكن لله الحمد لم يكن
هنالك مدنيين في الاماكن التي تهدمت بشكل
كامل يوجد بعض ايضا المنازل ايضا التي
هدمت بشكل كامل يوجد عدد من الاصابات
من المدنيين في منطقه الباب والاثارب
وايضا بعض الاصابات المتفرقه في بعض المدن
هذه الاصابات جاءت نتيجه التدافع ايضا
ونزول بعض الاحجار من المباني اثناء هروب
المدنيين الى الشوارع وايضا يوجد بعد بعض
الحالات التي كان
المدنيين قد قفزوا من الطوابق مما ادى الى
اصابتهم ولكن نؤكد الان انه لا يوجد اشخاص
تحت الانقاذ الزلزال ولكن شاهدنا الصور
لعدد من المواطنين وقد هرعوا الى الساحات
العامه
هل هناك يعني من خدمات متوفره مثل
الكهرباء طرق سالكه ولذلك خاصه في هذا
الظلام الدامس
الان اغلب المدنيين في شمال غرب سوريا هم
الان في الساحات العامه في الحدائق بعضهم
يستقل سيارتهم بالاضافه ان بعض المدنيين
هم الان لا يوجد شيء من هذا البرد الشديد
الان الكلمه المتداوله لجميع المدنيين في
شمال غرب سوريا وهي لوين الروح هاي الكلمه
انه اغلب المدنيين هلا هم عم يستخدموها
الابنيه متصدعه حاله هلع وقوف شديده
وكبيره جدا كان هذا الزلزال هو قوي ولكن
لم يمتد بثواني عديده ولكن هذا الخوف الان
يؤثر على جميع المدنيين في شمال غرب سوريا
لا يوجد حتى مخيمات تاوي الهاربين من جراء
هذا الزلزال او تاوي الاسر الان المتواجده
في الشوارع اغلب المدنيين كما اسلتهم
متواجدون في الشوارع ولكن في الساحات
العامه
اللون سياره جميعا لذلك في ظل هذا البرد
السليم رافق هذا الزلزال ايضا بعض الهزات
الارتداديه كما اكدنا الفرقنا لا تزال
متواجده في المدن وايضا في بعض
القرى لحد هذه اللحظه في حال طلب اي طارئ
ولكن اكد الجميع الفرق العامله في شمال
الغربي سوريا على امتداد جميعا ان لا يوجد
لله الحمد اي شخص عالق تحت الانقاذ جراء
هذا الزلزال لذلك نؤكد على جميع اهلنا
المدنيين عن عدم الرجوع الى المباني التي
حذرنا مسبقا بعدم الرجوع اليها لان مباني
عاجله للسقوط وقد ايضا سقطت جراءه لذلك
نعيد ونكرر الى اهلنا المدنيين جميعا بعدم
العوده الى المباني التي وجهت على انها
مباني غير ماهوله للسكن
اشكرك سيدي يازجي على هذه المعلومات
الجديده التي تفضلت بها فيما يتعلق بتاثير
هذا الزلزال في شمال سوريا اشكرك حتى